previously on TV since fatter sir
they called me Terry titties and that's
the truth with some cheese on it ain't
no meatloaf between these bonds there
are certain moments when I have this
horrible reminder of the scene in Willy
Wonka and that scarring boat ride is
cinema every goddamn time I recall it I
get that it would take a little more
info and the show was giving you to set
up your own meth lab but I do feel like
subliminally inserting the exact
chemical contents into our brain every
week with these opening credits is a
daddy responsible well I didn't have to
highlight and capitalize the last n in
Dean when they have a perfectly good
capital and in Norris to use how do you
play with my brain like this show
why show has time for this Gossett's to
yes you surprised your employer doesn't
make you clock in which would show legal
documentation of your whereabouts during
meth cooking it's so gross
they have to lick his junk Blue Mountain
State Spartacus blood and Sam the
Michael dick project the Ricky Gervais
show basketball wife Pretty Little Liars
Melissa and Joey and The Real Housewives
of Beverly Hills were all on the air in
2010 I think a hyena licking his balls
is way less offensive on air content
yeah [ __ ] I'm not sure this is what
Gatorade meant when they signed up for
product placement but you do you
breaking bad five minutes of passed
since won't began his fly hunt and I am
doing that thing or I forced myself to
see deeper meaning in the meaningless
you know like the fly is a totem symbol
and Walt's obsession emphasizes his
descent into moral depravity the
alternative is that this super great
episode was actually the TV since fans
trolling me and making me watch a
monotone bottle episode maybe Walt's
calculations are off because his problem
solving definitely is the answer to the
second equation is 13,000 299 and not
13,000 301 as it says on the paper I
don't even understand why won't thinks
this will work but what I find more
unbelievable is the fly hasn't moved
from its spot with shoes being hurled
close to it I watched this scene several
times to find an obvious CGI moment and
well I think I know when the stuntman
merges into the actor it's very hard to
tell this shot is really impressive I'm
God to see they spent a little bit of
the budget on a stunt well done with
that being said won't probably could
survive this but he would be a lot more
depth than what the
tiny band-aid he's wearing later
suggests so I'm assuming this
lipstick-stained cigarette his jeans
who's been dead for a while
sad no but as much as Jesse smokes in
this car there is no way this ashtray
hasn't been dumped out since this
cigarette was smoked
what kind of contaminant are we dealing
with here if what hesitates to tell
Jessie that the contaminant is a fly
it is likely because he knows how
ridiculous it is why risk making their
boss angry about delayed drugs over a
meaningless fly if the show wants me to
believe that Walt is truly convinced
that the fly contaminant is a priority
then he shouldn't be dancing around his
obsession this whole episode is built on
a fly of lies it's a fly feller is that
your fly saver man even back in 2010
Ryan Johnson was introducing wild and
unpopular Star Wars concepts this is a
swatter happen so we're quite well thank
you
does it because the flying is not dead
we make poison for people who don't care
all right we probably had the most
unpick e customers in the world
drive-through lanes at mcdonald's beg to
differ oh let me look this up before I
hate chocolate forever well good news
and bad news you two prints but good
news is he's wrong the bad news is that
rat hair is loud along with 60 insect
fragments Jessie smacking Walt in the
head with the fly saber is sorry not
sorry hilarious why would Jesse really
have a better chance over Walt's
smacking his own head Walt can feel the
fly it has far better sneak attack
probability if his arm comes up from
below I don't know where I know he wants
to trick Jesse and steal his keys but
Walt is suddenly very casual about this
door being open he has no idea of the
Flies out of the lab and now I am
stressing but what about the rags at the
base of the door for positive air
pressure well come back demand for
thoroughness and leaving no room for
error was slipping away just like my
interest in finishing this episode for a
man worried about contamination I would
think setting the full coffee cup on the
lid of your drug tank would be a major
nono I sit down and this man the
stranger engages me in conversation he's
a complete stranger
Harlan Coben is Breaking Bad
the moment that night I should never
have left home you know what should
happen in the final 15 minutes of a show
about nothing that is suffering from a
momentum deathtrap drug the lead with
sleeping pills and give him a speech
that lasts for 10 goddamn minutes and
where was this latter earlier we was
going for a shoot sorry for what a
lunatic the show wants you to think that
Walt is about to confess his part in
Jane's death but he isn't the ops to use
his final coherent communication to
direct Jesse off the ladder and back to
the cook this entire episode is false
tension hollow recollections and regret
holy it's like having sex with my
college girlfriend
couldn't chance saying it inside well I
know the labs wired for sound but Walter
didn't feel the need to clue Jessie and
earlier when he was saying things like
apologies totally boning us the man can
sleep with slats of light ribbon across
his face but wakes up to a fly so
another fly comes in showing you that
even if you kill one fly there's always
another one right around the corner that
will contaminate you so what is the flaw
is it Walt's growing insanity is it a
representation of how we become obsessed
with small things that ignore the big
picture is it maybe symbolic of Jeff
Goldblum all of those are good answers
but all in all this episode is made me
realize that I don't give a flying about
these kind of metaphors
me lies on its way watch out for it it's
far beyond anything your mind could ever
conceive
we should have equipment maintainer guys
and water boys needle dick needle dick
NATO dip tell us that it's tingle you'll
begin a luck